That's the plot of the horror
movie version of Jack Frost, also.
Yeah.
My favorite movie that I think I've talked about
way too many times on the show. Oh my God. What
What body part is the gear supposed to be?
It doesn't matter.
Let's not put too much thought into it.
There you go. Hey. Today, we are going to
talk about terrible TV shows that should never
be rebooted. Tom, what-
Brian.
What is a terrible TV show? Hi. What's a terrible
TV show that you think should not be rebooted?
I'm glad you asked, Brian. I was looking at the
article that we have about this
very subject, up on Looper.com.
On Looper.com?
On Looper.com.
Thank you, Nina. And number
one with a bullet on there,
Manimal. I don't know if you guys remember
Manimal. Who here remembers Manimal?
I do not.
Well, Nina, you're 12.
What's Manimal?
I am vaguely aware that Manimal
existed. I mean, you say, "Who remembers
Manimal?" It says it was on in 1983.
I am pretty sure you weren't born yet.
I mean, there's no way of knowing. I'm
a timeless beauty. But Manimal, 1983.
Tom, has always been here,
and Tom will always be here.
That's right.
I'd like to think you're right about
that. There's something more about me.
Manimal, if you get a chance, go check out
Manimal. It's not good. So the concept,
what we have here is a guy, a white guy, he
learns how to turn into different animals-
A man. A white man.
Because... A man, if you will.
Brian will.
And he learns how to do
this thing, because Africa.
Oh, no.
Yeah, he's in Africa, and then he isn't in
Africa, and because Africa happened to him,
some vague magic happened and
now he can turn into an animal.
Does the song Africa by Toto factor into this show
in any way, shape, or form? Because it's the only-
Only in my heart.
Way I'd be interested. Okay. Thank you.
If it did, that would improve it considerably.
Yeah, I would watch it if the whole show was
just that song playing over and over again. Sold.
A 22-minute music video with a new-
Mm-hmm.
Okay. You might talk to NBC about changing
their lineup for prime time this fall, because-
Perfect. I will give-
The worst thing.
Put the head of NBC's name
right down here, a call.
Perfect. We're doing terrific. Manimal. Fantastic.
So not good, only lasted eight episodes.
Real drag. What's interesting about it is
that Stan Winston, who generally speaking
can do no wrong, he passed away, did the special
effects for the man turning into imal segment.
There was a segment where the main character turns
into a panther, and a segment where he turns into
a hawk, and they're hit and miss. They're okay.
There's a couple of shots that are very American
Werewolf in London. And then there'll be just
one shot of what appears to be a taxidermied
panther paw with just plastic claws
getting pushed through the end of it.
It's not great.
So they would blow their budget on one scene and
be like, that's it folks. The rest of it's trash.
That very much appeared to have been
what happened, because he turned into
other animals and you never really saw that
part. That was left to your imagination.
It's like, "Look, stock footage
of a cheetah. I mean Manimal."
Yeah.
Did they ever say he turned
into an animal offscreen?
Like someone's like, "Oh, he turned into a bird."
Totally. But it's like he's not even in the shot?
A hundred percent. Yeah. Turns
into snakes and stuff. And like
it's just sort of left to your
imagination, which is fine.
Wouldn't it be great, though, if ...
yeah, I think that what Nina's getting
at though is like, wouldn't it be
great if the transformation scene
100% still happened, but with
people just watching, like-
That's exactly what I meant is
like, it's just reaction shots.
"It's incredible. He's turning into a snake!
This is the craziest thing I've ever seen!"
"Whoa! I didn't know he could do that!"
I think under my direction, we
should maybe reboot Manimal.
This is a perfect plan. I think what if
we rebooted it and called it Womanimal?
It's interesting that you bring that up
because a couple years after it was canceled-
Oh, no.
The creator of the show brought the character
back in another show that ... I want to say it
was called ... Nina, you're not going to believe
me here, but I think the show was called Nightman.
I don't believe you at all.
I'm going to look this up real quick.
Did he ever fight the Dayman?
Maybe that was-
Did he do karate kicks across the stage?
A planned episode for Season Two.
Did he have cat eyes?
He had-
I'm asking all the right questions.
You're doing a perfect job.
Thank you. I'm sorry, you can't say the word
Nightman and expect me to not like already
have the Always Sunny song stuck in my head.
Hang on a second.
Totally fair.
Lodged in my brain.
This actor, the actor who played
Manimal was named Simon MacCorkindale.
Sorry. Mr. MacCorkindale. That's a funny name.
You're right. I buried the lead on that one.
Simon MacCorkindale. I hope that's a stage name,
because that's a great name to choose. That's all.
Not that I'd think it's an unfortunate name.
I think it's just a very exciting name.
I wish my name was MacCorkindale.
It's fun to say.
Brian MacCorkindale.
You can change it. There's still time.
1998. So, a full 14 years after the show,
after Manimal man went off the air, they
brought the character back, trying to give him a
backdoor pilot for his daughter to become the new
Manimal on a program called Nightman
that also didn't last very long.
Wow. Backdoor pilot on a flop.
These are facts.
Yep.
Pretty cool.
All right.
So that's Manimal, I guess. Yeah.
Yeah, you bet it is.
Nina, what do you think?
I was going to say my pick's a
little similar. It is not Manimal.
Okay.
But I'm going to lead into it by talking about
the concept of taking a commercial or a very
short bit and making it into a TV series.
Oh no.
Ted Lasso.
No, no. Ted Lasso did that. Right. And-
Ernest.
I'm going to use Ted movies and Ernest and the
Ernest movies, but that's movies. I'm talking TV.
Max Headroom.
Oh my God. I forgot about Max Headroom.
See, I'm getting schooled here.
So there's a few. There's a few.
But I mean, I would say Ted Lasso is
like an unnervingly good example of it,
in that Ted Lasso was a good show
populated with well written characters.
And it's really like, you can't believe
that it's a bit Jason Sudeikis probably
came up with in five minutes is like
out there winning Emmys. I mean,
that dude probably came up with that off
the cuff at ESPN headquarters or whatever.
That's like if the Coneheads movie
was nominated for several Oscars.
Right, and it's crazy that that's how the
origin of this deeply emotional, gut wrenching,
but also hilarious show. But I'm not here to talk
about Ted Lasso, because that's a great show and
I love it. I'm here to talk about the opposite
of what happens when you take a commercial that
already sucks and you make it suck a lot harder.
And that is the series Cavemen, which was based-
Oh, yeah.
Great show.
On the Geico Caveman commercials.
Good call. Starring Nick Kroll.
Nick Kroll.
Starring Nick Kroll. Yes. And I remembered
I didn't watch this show when it was on,
because why would I have done that?
I watched the first episode.
So I watched seven minutes of
the first episode today and wow.
Very good.
It caused physical pain. It's so deeply unfunny.
So first of all, the prosthetics that they wear as
the cavemen are so limiting that they can't really
do anything with their mouths or faces, and they
all sound like they have a big wad of chewing gum
in their mouths, but like it's just sitting there.
Because they got the fake teeth.
Well, yeah, it's like the Rami Malek
in Bohemian Rhapsody problem where it's
just like the teeth just get in the way of
everything. I hate that movie, but sorry.
But yeah. So like it premiered, oh
my God. I didn't even look at the
dates before this. It only aired
from October to November of 2007.
Yeah, apparently.
You made it one month.
And also to just back up real fast, the
commercials that these were from was ... It was a
Geico commercial, and it was a guy who looked like
a caveman on a automated sidewalk at an airport.
And then he passes a billboard that says, "Saving
money with Geico is so easy, even a caveman could
do it." And then he looks upset and everyone,
it was like caveman, cave mania is what it was.
Right. And then Geico, I don't know, Geico has
too many, I'm not the first person to make this
observation, way too many mascots. Like pick
one. You can't have a caveman and a gecko. And
I feel like there's a million other things
that I can't even think of right now, but-
The little pile of money with the eyes on it.
Yeah. Thanks for making
sure I don't sleep tonight.
Where's that TV show?
So Cavemen was a bad show. I think we all know
that. It also, I didn't remember this happening,
there was a controversy over the pilot, because
it was accused of using cavemen as stand-ins
for like racial inequality. And it was also
set in Atlanta, and it had some very like
unsettling, bad undertones, undertones.
I don't think they were under like-
They were tones.
I think they were tones.
Pretty much.
Over tones even.
Yeah, they moved it to California, but I think
they still had Southern accents. And so it was
like, why do they have those? What? This
is super out of context. And so yeah, like
it was ruined by critics. Everybody hated
it. It got canceled almost immediately.
Yeah. 13 episodes were produced. The final
six never aired. So seven aired. That's it.
Ross classic.
Bad show. No, it's not, though. If anyone rebooted
this, I would personally request that they go
to jail. It would be a crime, I think under
maybe the Geneva Convention, to reboot this show.
I'll have a legal expert check on that for me.
But yeah. I mean, this felt like a slam dunk
pick to me. Nobody out there is like, "Wow,
I really loved Cavemen." I mean,
and the humor on it too is so ...
It is bad.
There's all these weird, heavy pauses where no one
knows what to do, because the jokes are so clearly
unfunny. It's really weirdly misogynistic, like
out of the gate, they're just gross about women.
I mean, they are Neanderthals.
Yeah. But they keep being like,
but we're not. One of them
has a laptop and is playing solitaire and
is doing his dissertation for his PhD.
Brian's laughing.
So like the whole joke is that they're
not Neanderthals, but it also has this
weird ... The intro is like "Cavemen have always
been here. And we always will" much like Tom,
and I was like, so are they immortal?
Have they been alive this whole time?
This isn't what we do in The
Shadows, a good show, like I just-
There are so many conversations
that needed to happen from pitch to-
And apparently everybody just went, "Yeah, this is
going to make us bags of money. Great. Go for it."
This is going to sell a lot of insurance guys.
I'm guessing a lot of people were
let go from, I believe it was ABC,
after that ... It was ABC,
after that all went down.
It must have been expensive, too, because you have
to do all the prosthetics, you
have to license it from Geico.
You do have to license it, but I was going to say
the prosthetics don't look like they cost a whole-
Halloween store?
Nina.
Yeah. Or like Amazon, maybe.
It was just like a kit.
Did you get to the part in the first episode where
they realize that maybe it's the humans
who are the uncivilized ones after all?
I think that's the whole joke.
You just described the whole show.
They're at like a garden party?
Yeah. Yeah.
It's some pretty smart stuff, Nina.
You're right. It just went over my head. Anyway,
Caveman. That's my pick. It's a bad
show. Nobody make it again. Thank you.
I'm going to briefly touch
on a few from the Looper.com
article. I'm so mad. I didn't think of Cavemen,
because that is a show I actually watched.
I can't believe you watched
it. I didn't think anybody did.
I mean I watched the first episode. I just
mean I saw it when it happened, you know?
Right.
Who was your favorite character?
What?
Who's your favorite character on Cavemen?
Nick Kroll.
The Nick Kroll caveman.
The one that is Nick Kroll.
The one I remember being Nick
Kroll. One that's on here.
I think my little brother had a t-shirt
that said that, Nick Kroll caveman.
I'm going to cherry pick a
few here. We've got Facts
of Life. I don't remember that being
terrible, but that would be weird to-
Yeah.
Reboot, like all these girls in a boarding school
in 2021. How would, I don't know about that one.
Isn't that just Gossip Girl?
Yeah. It's just a worse Gossip Girl.
Love Boat. How would Love Boat in 2021
go? Right? Like it would just be a reality show.
It would be that cruise that they
wouldn't let dock in March of 2020.
So sort of like what they did with Fantasy
Island. They make it a horror movie.
This is the gritty reboot of Love Boat. Yeah.
Blumhouse presents the Love Boat.
The Hate Boat.
Perfect.
My favorite joke is just saying
the opposite of the thing.
Works every time.
Yeah. Now ALF is another show I
remember from my childhood days.
That we don't want more of?
Well, he eats cats. I think that's problematic.
I think ALF would be canceled for eating cats.
ALF. So the premise of ALF is that an alien
crash lands on earth into the garage of a
normal suburban family. And for whatever reason,
instead of calling the police or the government,
they adopt him like a roommate, and it's
terrible for the family. Like it doesn't go well.
It's very annoying. And as mentioned,
he keeps trying to eat their cat.
It was performed by a Muppet-style puppet. So
you've got one puppeteer with a hand here and
a hand here and then a second puppeteer
doing the other hand, pretty sure.
And sometimes when they needed full body shots,
they would just stick a kid or a
small person into an ALF costume, and-
Wasn't there an episode where he-
Your brain would just melt
watching it. It was so upsetting.
There's an episode where he goes on a
blind date with a literal blind woman.
Okay? Because it's the only
way that he could find love.
That. No, that's a 30 Rock joke.
I'm fairly certain that this happened.
That's just Kenneth.
It's also a 30 Rock joke.
Because Kenneth does that. Yeah.
Oh, that's right. That's right.
Yeah. Other salient points about ALF,
I remember that his name was Gordon Shumway.
He's from the planet Melmac, and there was
a cartoon based on ALF that I also watched.
And he made an appearance in the cartoon
all stars. No more drugs. Thank you, please.
That's right. He teamed up with Garfield,
the Care Bears, the Muppet Babies, Alvin
and the Chipmunks, Slimer, Bugs Bunny.
Wow, it's a regular Avengers.
Don't smoke pot. And it worked.
Yeah, when a bunch of cartoon
characters gather to tell you not to
do drugs, you either definitely listen-
Or all of the toys in your room come to life.
Or you definitely don't.
You're like, I need something to make this
disappear. Things have gone wrong. Another
one on here which I don't think I'm going to say it
is a terrible show, because I remember it fondly,
but you certainly could not reboot it today, Who's
the Boss, where the premise is a woman in charge,
a man who's a nanny. What? And that's the whole
premise. Now back in the eighties, it was fine.
It was so zany that a woman
might be in charge of something.
It was a fine little show that kind of challenged
gender conventions at the time. And you've got
a very charismatically lead in Tony Danza
and all the rest of the cast, Judith Light,
other actors whose names I've
forgotten, but they're all there, too.
No, I get it. It's a product of its time.
I'm not going to crap on it for like,
they were trying then. Now it would be
like, what? Yeah, that's just normal.
You'd be like, "What's the big
deal?" That's just like every day.
Right.
It's fine. But one that's not on here that
I remember existing during the course of
this conversation was a show called Viper. Do
you remember that? Has anyone heard of Viper?
So you remember Knight Rider and how the premise
of that was like, there's a guy who does missions
with his super smart car who can talk to you.
Imagine that, but take away the part where
the car can talk. That's Viper and also add in
licensing from Dodge and their new car, the Viper.
Okay.
And that's it.
So it's the opposite of Cavemen where
it's a show that is a commercial,
not a commercial that is a show.
Correct. And it's just a really
fancy car. I think it morphs or
something from a regular Dodge Viper to the
special effect version of the Dodge Viper.
I thought you were going to
say it morphs from a regular
one to like the one with the nicer cup
holders and the better stereo system.
Three more options.
Yeah. It morphs into the
upsell version of the car.
Undercoating.
Could you imagine like a new version of
that show that's like a different car
company? It's like PT Cruiser, and he goes
around solving crimes in his station wagon.
Oh, that's shippable.
That's actually kind of a good idea.
That's not bad. That's actually really good.
Detective PT Cruiser.
Honestly. I think we could distract Elon
Musk from doing a lot of other stuff if we
offered him a show called Tesla, and he just
drove around in a Tesla and solved crimes.
He's the star. He gets to solve crimes.
We could distract him for a while. Yeah.
He solves crimes by installing
giant batteries in people's garages.
Yeah. That'd keep that guy busy.
And casually say awful things. So yeah,
there's that. And then I just thought
of another show, just now, called
Turbo Teen. Do you know Turbo Teen?
All I can think of is Turbo Team from
I Think You Should Leave, but go on.
All right. I have to pull it up for you now.
Was this the kid that could turn into a car?
That's correct.
Oh.
Okay, cool.
So basically the premise of this show,
this is a cartoon from the eighties
where this kid's driving his convertible, right?
And he accidentally crashes into an experiment
that's happening somewhere in a science lab,
and he gets zapped by the ray and then this
happens. So just watch this video unfold.
That's the plot of the horror
movie version of Jack Frost, also.
Yeah, exactly.
My favorite movie that I think I've
talked about way too many times on
the show. Oh my God. What in ... What
body part is the gear supposed to be?
It's all ... it doesn't matter.
I wouldn't ... Let's not put
too much thought into it.
There you go.
Yeah. It's disgusting, isn't it?
It's really horrific to watch.
Never, no one make that. That's another
crime. Straight to jail with you.
So yeah, that's a show.
Make a live action reboot of that and
really lean into just the body horror of it.
The face.
Star Trek Insurrection.
You know what? Make David Lynch do it. Make
David Lynch make this movie and I would watch it.
Absolutely. Oh my God, no, a
children's television program.
Turbo Teen.
Honestly. I'd watch the crap out of
that. Put the weirdest person in charge.
Turbo Teen, transform!
The guy who's whole origin story's that he lived
in Philly for a little while and got really weird.
I love this.
So yeah. So those are our picks. Anyway,
that's the end.
Thanks for watching.Please hit like and subscribe. Do you knowwhere Curly's gold is? It's in my pocket.